really comes down to communication and
trying to make sure everything hums and
works seamlessly and everyone within the
company communicates respectfully with
each other it's been one of the biggest
challenges i think i think after a few
years of really working hard at it where
we're starting to get there
but it's something that i underestimated
before
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders today is a
very special episode because we're
talking about transformations and in
ways that are very very unexpected meet
jeff chardell the founder and ceo of
humble brands incorporated
during his career working in the
high-tech corporate world jeff chardell
learned that the deorder he used daily
was filled with harmful chemicals linked
to cancer alzheimer's disease and other
illnesses
he realized his body was likely
absorbing these nasty chemicals and
decided something had to change
jeff wanted to see if he could make a
truly natural deodorant that actually
worked with as few ingredients as
possible
after extensive research and a lot of
trial and error in his san francisco
kitchen jeff stumbled onto a magic
formula
just four clean and simple ingredients
would change the world of all natural
deodorants for good
not only was just formula made from
ingredients found in his own kitchen but
it was more effective at naturally
beating odors than anything else out
there
jeff chardell welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from hawaii thank
you so much for joining me how are you
ah michael doing well thanks for having
me on today i really appreciate you
taking the time to chat
we're going to have so much fun jeff
such a
an unconventional journey filled with
pretty much everything that i want to do
in my life
that's what you're doing and i think
it's just pretty remarkable both on the
entrepreneurial level but also on on the
humane level and and i'm excited to to
sort of unravel with you some of these
incredible experiences like business
development at netscape
original browser of course
aol then and then and google a very
early employee transitioning to more
different online things with with
cosmetics and estee la
adele and then transitioning to
a natural deodorant
and
both with a physical relocation but also
an entrepreneurial relocation so so jeff
how does this happen what's what's going
on there walk me through
this crazy journey of yours and
transitioning at the end palo alto to
new mexico and hawaii
yeah yeah no it's a good question i get
asked that a lot um you know it's i
spent as you mentioned most of my career
living in the bay area working in the
tech industry and um last company i was
at as you mentioned was google
loved it had a great experience there
and and when i left i was ready for a
life change and
um the last year or two i was there i
traveled a tremendous amount flying back
and forth to london every couple weeks
and when i moved to new mexico i was
just trying to figure out ways to
change my life detoxify things a little
bit and one of the first things i
discovered as i started reading about
all of these external factors that we
can control in our life
is how bad traditional antiperspirants
are for you
um the connection between those and
alzheimer's disease and breast cancer
and lymph node cancer and kidney disease
and the list kind of goes on and so
i tried the products that were out there
at the time the natural products natural
deodorants and none of them worked well
for me and so
i went and started mixing in my kitchen
started giving to family and friends
getting feedback
and i ended up creating our my first
version of the product which i called
jeff's pit butter uh the the crazy
caricature of my face on there but it
was really just kind of a
tongue-in-cheek side project
and more and more people started asking
for it and then um i ended up having a
son about six and a half years ago and
so when that happened i decided to uh
take things a little more seriously as
far as the business as well and uh
rebranded the humble brands
and we've been growing the business ever
since we've got a company-owned facility
in taos new mexico
we make all of our products at our
facility except our soap but
to your point i never would have
imagined that it would have gone from
kind of internet dude to you know
deodorant king but here i am
i i love it and i love how you're
mentioning deodorant dude and
internet dude and deodorant king i i
love that
now jeff take me back to i believe 2009
and
you know where are you at you're
mentioning that that you're looking for
ways to detoxify and you're looking and
you're becoming
much more conscious about you know your
well-being both physically and mentally
and in all and your surrounding what is
going on there
yeah it's um it really just kind of an
awareness of i've always led a very
healthy lifestyle i've exercised i've
you know been very active i've eaten
well but you know there as you get older
you there are certain things that we can
control and certain things we can't
control and so i just felt like let me
try to control as many of the aspects of
what i'm able to impact in my life as i
as i can
one of the the things that struck me
though
is even if you look at natural products
that are out there all natural products
are not created equal if you look at the
ingredients list many times you're going
to see huge sets of ingredients lots of
extraneous ingredients
and not always the healthiest
ingredients for you and so
when i was at google i had the
opportunity to spend a little bit of
time with yvonne chenard uh the founder
of patagonia and he would come through
and
one of the things he said that really
stuck with me
is most companies when they develop
products they end up adding as many
bells and whistles to the products as
they can and then they're left with this
swiss army knife of a product that they
launch into the market
patagonia does the opposite they strip
out as many of the elements of the
product as they can until they're left
with just the core essence of that
product that still performs the way it
should
and then they launch that product and i
love that that concept of simplicity
and so when i set out to create a better
deodorant
i really incorporated the that ethos
into
my development and
our simple our products have simple set
of ingredients four set of ingredients
cornstarch baking soda beeswax
fractionated coconut oil
all simple you understand what they are
safe enough to eat and then we have
essential oils that we add to it and
we've expanded beyond deodorant since
then but that same simple ingredient
healthy good for you ethos continues
through all of our products
that first day deciding that you're
going to look for ways to to change what
i see on the shelf around me that is
going to just harm my body
how does that what do you even start
with in that moment
meaning how do you even begin something
like this actually how do you go how do
you take the first step forward
yeah
they always say necessity is the mother
of invention and so
i just started doing some research i've
always found that i'm curious about a
lot of things and so started trying to
figure out what really causes
the the body odor that that many people
uh experience and
it's the bacteria that's created um uh
that that grows in your body uh under
your armpits and certain other parts of
your uh of your anatomy
and uh
my my first push into this
i used baking soda to neutralize the
bacteria that causes body odor and that
with a combination of corn starch which
absorbs moisture so you didn't feel
really sticky and it was just kind of
those two powdery substances i put
together and put on my armpit and it
kind of worked um but at the end of the
day i had like a loaf of bread under
there right so i figured out i figured
there had to be a better way than that
and so then i started playing around
with different waxes and oils as binding
agents and it was i love to cook and so
just kind of for me it was a fun
experimentation in the kitchen
and going over a six-month period of
time until i finally found something
that worked
how many iterations do you think you've
done
to find the right fit
i would say
30 or more
easily oh my god and we're still always
always doing fine tuning at this point
we have a a team of people now who who
will do the fine tuning i've they
they've intentionally pulled me out of
the kitchen which is probably a good
thing
uh the test lab but uh yeah probably
early on 30 iterations or so to get to
the the base product
fantastic now jeff as you're growing the
business and as you're now transitioning
from you know understanding in the
journey understanding that okay you have
something something interesting here
something that is very valuable to
humanity not just appealing to a
consumer but it can actually improve
improve their health
how do you go about thinking then as an
entrepreneur now not you know you are
coming from the from the internet side
and so you obviously understand commerce
and you and you've done it before with
your own company
how do you go about thinking through
building the humble brand brand
um you know it's a multi-pronged
approach and it's as you said using
direct to consumer tools that we have
out there whether it's building our
website and all the tools that we can
bolt on and tap into our website to grow
that business uh working with other
third party e-commerce providers
but really
a lot of it has been
a it's been a grassroots effort and so
coming from the internet space uh and
you've spent a good part of your career
in tech as well
we're used to
you launch a product in in in tech and
very quickly you see if it's going to be
a success or not right if people adopt
it's like all right we've got that
hockey stick
going in the right direction we know
that it's going to be a success right
cpg brands are very different and it
definitely is something that i
underestimated when i started the
company uh we've been around for six
years or so and um we're in about 8 000
stores now but it's taken a lot of work
to get into those stores and we really
it was a grass roots effort of getting
into a lot of independent retailers
early on and
my feeling is
the
a lot of times the the bigger chains
don't want to take
a a risk on a startup brand and so it's
it's hard to get into the big guys but
you go into the smaller medium-sized
chains they're kind of the the canary in
the coal mine for changes that are
happening in the industry and so the
bigger guys will look towards the
smaller guys the smaller independents um
to see where the future is and so we
really put our energies into growing
that side of the business the smaller
retails to start retailers to start with
and then we knew eventually the bigger
ones would come which is starting to
happen now
and for the end consumers
what sort of the validation process that
you went through to understand how the
public is perceiving this this is
something different than than where
we're used to
as far as just the product you mean
early on
the question i would get asked the most
when i would try to push our deodorant
is does it work
and
i think there was a lot of there was a
lot of hesitancy
towards natural products thinking you
had to have
these chemically laden products in order
for them to do what they should do
and i don't get asked that anymore which
is really interesting i think it's
because people have kind of gone beyond
um
generally people have gone beyond that
concern that a natural product can't
perform maybe not 100 but 90 80 or 90 as
good as what a chemical product would so
look an antiperspirant you don't sweat
with it right it blocks your sweat pores
but that's part of the problem and then
you've got this these this entry point
in your armpits for
uh for chemicals that you don't want to
go into your body so
you may be you know a little bit damp at
times when you wear a natural deodorant
but the cornstarch kicks in and the
dampness goes away so maybe it doesn't
keep you a hundred percent as dry
as an antiperspirant does but it's not
going to be bad for you and
i think it's just that perception though
so people have changed their perception
over time that
we can get a product that is just about
as good as we've been using before and
oftentimes as good and um
uh and and be happy with the efficacy
and not be worried about putting
chemicals onto and into our body
so now you know six years later
uh you know in the in the tech world
we're always talking about you know
passion and motivation and and chasing
after you know
six years later what are you still most
excited about in what you're doing is it
the entrepreneurial journey that you're
on is it about getting the creating this
beautiful brand that people associate
with is it just making people healthier
which part are you really most motivated
by
you know it's two things um one is
definitely building
building a brand that um delivers a
message of of awareness and awareness of
again what we put onto our bodies is
important as what we put in our bodies
but there are side benefits to building
this brand that i hadn't really thought
of before that i really enjoy so one is
creating
jobs for people who uh oftentimes
haven't worked in a more professional
industry before we've got 35 employees
and growing as a company and uh many
people who work for humble have been on
board since the very early early days
and so being able to provide you know
exciting meaningful employment to people
is great and then the other thing is
we work with a number of charitable
organizations through one percent for
the planet again an organization founded
by ivan cenard
from patagonia but
one of the organizations in particular
that we work with is charity water and
we funded a number of wells so far with
charity water providing
clean water to over a thousand people
now and that's exciting um
we take for granted living in these
these uh
first world countries you could turn the
tap on and drink the water and bathe in
the water and you're not gonna get sick
but 700 million people
in the world don't have that luxury and
so if in some small way we can bring
that luxury to people by by planting
wells putting wells into these areas
where people can get clean water um
it's it's just it's it's it's a
wonderful feeling and so um
those are some of the side benefits that
i never really thought of
when i started humble
i love it and i want to continue with
this you know the same line of thought
if you're going up 30 000 feet in here
and you're today you're looking back at
this journey that you're on and the
different transitions that you've made
what are some things that you've
discovered
about yourself or about you know that
everything around you that you perhaps
wouldn't have known if you hadn't gone
that route after working at google and
after being in in the internet world for
for and doing some fantastic things
there
what does this change
made you realize either about yourself
or about the world around you
you know i
i always knew that we were all
interconnected but i think a lot of it
comes down to that realizing that kind
of everything is is interconnected um
and
boy
as far as changes of things that i
hadn't known before
um
you know i think a lot of it though
is
coming down to
for me personally
um doing things
that
i
hadn't done before you know dealing with
trademark issues dealing with employee
issues dealing with things like that um
when you work for a larger company
a lot of times you are
shielded from that and so
when you
have your own company you're not
um
and
it could be lonely too
to be honest you know their employee
issues comes up covid two years ago
where we're we're questioning is the
company going to continue or not you
know the retailers are closing you
you've got to be
the um
you've got to be the
the cheerleader within the company to
keep people excited but secretly
sometimes you're kind of wondering if if
you're going to make it and you can't
always turn to the people that you rely
to within the company during those times
and sometimes it's hard to find someone
to turn to to figure that out
so you know in in retrospect and
thinking about your question more deeply
i would say that's one of the big things
i hate to say lonely lonely when you're
running a company but it can be
sometimes and so having having you know
solid people to turn to
um when things get difficult
right
what is the most challenging piece of
this whole thing
i'm asking some hard questions today i'm
sorry but this is really fascinating
yeah yeah i know it's okay
the most challenging piece i would say
it is creating a company
where people work seamlessly with each
other so
again if if we look at all my tech
career
it was spent with working with uh you
know people in sales and bizdev and
legal and whatnot but but with humble
we've got that element and then we have
manufacturing as well
and so
a lot of different personalities in all
these different parts and then you throw
manufacturing and manufacturing
personalities in and
making sure that things
come along the way they should
and
email exchanges between people who are
in the production floor and people who
are in sales it's amazing how quickly
something can be misinterpreted and all
of a sudden things can escalate and it's
these are situations that i didn't
experience as much
working
in kind of just a pure tech environment
and so
it really comes down to communication
and trying to make sure everything hums
and works seamlessly and everyone within
the company communicates respectfully
with each other it's been one of the
biggest challenges i think i think after
a few years of really working hard at it
we're we're starting to get there um but
it's something that i underestimated
before and uh i no longer underestimate
the importance of that
amazing jeff i really want to thank you
for taking the time to to city with me
and to share with me you know a little
bit about your journey i think it's just
so fascinating and and i think part of
it is because like i said i started off
in the in the beginning i am jealous in
a lot of a lot of it and i think
especially this last part and i think
that
i won't be surprised if i find myself at
some point going after an endeavor like
this because i think that that while it
may be different and very similar in a
lot of ways to
our work and tech in the day-to-day at
the end you can tell just how passionate
you are jeff both about the cause of
what you're doing about but your
personal fulfillment with it about the
journey itself but what i'm
what i'm inspired by it's the the
intentionality with which you understand
that you're having a strong impact on
the lives of the people that that work
in this organization
that you care deeply about the the
interconnectedness of the people
the the humble approach
of the humble brand and uh and beyond
all that i just love the product and
i've been using it daily since
since i got it so thank you very very
much for introducing it to me
and really jeff thank you stay safe and
stealthy
[Music]